so i wanted to start today by taking you
back to the early days of using css for
layout
so those of us who are sort of early
adopters uh we gave up on our nested
tables and we tried to use absolute
positioning to do our layout and we
quickly realized that meant that we
ended up with our footers overlaying our
content so we then moved on to floats
and the layout that we wanted to achieve
became known as the holy grail
and it looked like this
three column layout with fixed width
sidebars and a flexible middle section
uh with the source in a good order for
screen readers because we you know we
were already thinking about text-based
browsers and screen readers and so on
so this was before responsive design it
was before everybody had clever phones
and things so the aim was what we call a
liquid layout so one that would work
with all possible screen resolutions uh
you know 640 by 480 800 by 600 and those
really lucky people who are on 1024x768
and we all dreamed of a time when
everybody would have a screen that size
simpler times
but with responsive design came this new
complexity the need to translate designs
created in photoshop which is pretty
much how everything was built you know
we'd get a fixed thing we'd have to turn
it into a design we wanted to translate
those into you know flexible columns
now the old liquid designs basically
meant just saying to the designers look
it's only the middle bit that might
stretch a bit i know you might get
slightly longer length line lengths but
it's fine
but once we got to responsive design you
know we were having to sort of change up
the whole layout
um and you know that that was quite a
jump for people who were designing for
the web and so to try and make that
easier we tried to work out grid layouts
basically we're like well how can we
make these grids that we have in our
photoshop design how can we make that
work for the web and so we started to
get all these kind of these frameworks
layout frameworks they started off being
pretty simple um this is from the 960
grid system anyone used that back in the
day anyone yet yeah you see loads of
people using this we were going to these
sites were copied and pasting this stuff
and using it in our designs and so we
didn't have to worry about maths
basically
and then we've got things like bootstrap
and so on which really you know a lot of
people were using for the for the grid
although there were lots of other things
that these frameworks were doing but
under the hood anything that was using a
float based grid was doing the same
thing sizing things in percentages and
pushing them around they looked like a
grid
so you know something like this that's
how you get your your grid layout
essentially using css and
well there were problems with that
so the biggest problems that people had
you know you have asked people what
problems you got with layout and
clearing floats because that was quite
annoying
um and getting equal height columns that
was also very annoying and designers
could not understand why this was just
an impossibility on the web and to have
one thing as tall as the other
so that was floats
and like we were building things and we
had the frameworks it was fine we were
able to do our jobs and but then flexbox
came along
and they said flexbox basically solved
all of our problems with floats
um it
allowed us to create a grid which had
equal height columns and we didn't have
to worry about clearing that was
fantastic
and i think because it solved those
problems so well
no one actually looked at what flexbox
was supposed to be for
everyone just took flexbox and said it's
floats plus
let's do this stuff much better we don't
worry about clearing anymore you know
bootstrap we built their grid system
using flex
but a flexbox based grid is just like a
float-based grid you size things in
percentages and you push them around
and so people started having problems
with flexbox and this was generally
expressed by people saying it was weird
and it was hard and it didn't do a grid
very well
um
lining things up in two dimensions that
was hard you know creating gaps between
flex items you know it was just a bit
weird so then we got grid layout
and so when grid came along it solved
those problems we could line things up
in in two dimensions we could make our
12 column or whatever grid much better
um and that was pretty cool and you know
i've been building to the web for a very
long time you know i was i was just a
freelance web developer for a very long
time and i think you know doing the same
things faster and in a less fragile way
is really really good and that shouldn't
be discounted the fact that these layout
methods let us do that because there's
lots of common patterns that go back to
the dawn of the web
um
but
we miss a lot about these layout methods
if we try to use them just to create a
better fixed grid
and this thinking about grid as just a
better version of flexbox
this comes from this place of not using
flex for what it's good at what it was
designed for
in know flexbox flexible box layout is
for making squishy things
so again if we look at float based
layouts um if you are making a float
based layout you have to decide how big
everything was up front
and make the boxes that size and then
just stick stuff into them because if
you didn't give things a size they just
sort of wrap around like this and look
all a bit messy so what you would do is
you know you would give them their
percentage size you could end up giving
them all the same width and so big
things would get squashed into small
boxes and small things that have loads
of space around them um
and you could go around and carefully
tweak those percentages but then what
happens if the site's translated what
happens if you go into german for
example and you have enormous words in
there um it all breaks then you have to
do another style sheet for that language
and things and that's all really messy
so that's what flexbox was designed for
you've got a bunch of differently sized
things you don't really know even how
big they are you throw them at that
layout method and it returns the best
layout for those things
taking into account how big they are
now this is intrinsic sizing it's layout
looking at the natural size of the
content
and then working out how big it is
rather than extrinsic sizing which is
when we create a box and we stuff the
content into it
so this intrinsic sizing is the default
behavior of flexbox
so if you want to make a grid of equal
sized columns with flexbox you basically
turn that behavior off
you tell the flex items to ignore their
intrinsic size you basically say you've
got no intrinsic size and you go back to
stuffing content into pre-defined boxes
and that's what any flexbox based grid
is doing
so it's flexbox that kind of introduced
this inside out intrinsically sized
layout but we pretty much ignored it for
a few years because we were just so busy
looking for a thing that would let us
create better grids
so what then of grid layouts i mean
surely that is just for making fixed
columns and popping things into them and
it certainly can be
sometimes that's that's definitely what
you want you want to have a regular grid
and lay things out on it
it's really good at that
grid makes really good demo um you know
i spoke about grid for a very long time
before it even landed and you know it
makes fantastic demos you can do all
this stuff in a couple of lines of css
and so we get our nice equally sized
grid
but
if you look at the template definition
that i used more closely
i didn't just use one fr for each of my
tracks i used this i used min max 0
1fr now the reason i used minmax01fr
when i wanted a regularly sized grid is
because of this
if you use just one fr and then you
place some big thing into one of the
tracks so here i've replaced one of the
words with an image of that creature
that track grows to accommodate it it
doesn't stay you know in this case one
sixth of of the available space
because grid two
is designed to allow for this inside out
sort of sizing
one fr is actually min max auto 1fr
so look at the auto size the intrinsic
size of the content and then share out
whatever space is left over
there's a tiny difference in the
algorithm between how grid works this
out and flexbox works this out which
means that you will see this behavior
less often in grid you will more often
in grid if you use 1fr get equal sized
columns
but it but it's there and it's baked
into the way that grid works
so this is really what i mean by layout
from the inside out our new layout
methods
start with the size of the content and
then work out and that is completely
upside down compared to what we have
been doing on the web like forever you
know we've always been defining size and
then stuffing stuff into it
and so once you realize that you can
start to do some really neat things um
this is kind of my my favorite little
demo um at one time it was quite hard to
do stuff like little decorations you
know lines either side of a heading that
would be responsive that wouldn't end up
sort of squashing the heading into a
tiny box in the middle and i do this
using um grid and generated content so
i'm basically making my heading into a
grid
um the actual heading text goes into the
auto size track i've got two one of our
tracks either side and i'm using some
generated content basically to to put a
line in there you can do that sort of
stuff with lots and lots of different
little patterns and there's lots of
times where you just want to add a bit
of decoration you can do that with grid
and it works really nicely
and so the thing about having squishy
things and having these layout methods
that that let us do this sort of stuff
is then
you kind of get this next level of
things that people want to be able to do
because they're like oh this is cool
oh but you know if we can have these
these nice boxes what happens if i want
their height to be the same as their
width and what you're asking for there
is you're asking for aspect ratio
now in the past about the only time that
we kind of came up against the need for
aspect ratio is when we wanted to put
video content onto our pages
and and probably pretty much everyone
has probably come up against this now if
you stick you know html5 video or an
image onto a web page it maintains its
aspect ratio and all through css we're
very careful not to stretch and squash
the aspect ratio of things that have got
an intrinsic aspect ratio
the problem comes if i want to embed a
youtube video with an iframe on my
responsive page and i embed that and
it's got a you know a flexible width but
what about the height
and then we end up having to use some
sort of
maybe use some javascript or you know
what a lot of people have used is is
this thing that we call the padding hack
um this this uses the fact that if you
set your padding using percentages
the values for the block dimension is
copied from the inline dimension it
gives you a sort of hacky way to give
you the aspect ratio of that box it most
of the time works when it doesn't work
it's just really problematic and you
have to use javascript
but that's how we've been dealing with
aspect ratios
um so we've now got this aspect ratio
property though that lets us just like
declare an aspect ratio
so we can now set a box to conform to
whatever aspect ratio we might like
um so that might be because you've set
an explicit size in one dimension of
your books or that size is just been
defined by whatever is available
and then you'll be able to maintain the
aspect ratio
so i mean that solves your supply frame
problem and this demo has got a couple
of good tracks and and i've dropped
boxes that are set to have an aspect
ratio and their width is defined by the
track that they're in so it'll be bigger
or smaller but they always keep their
height in the ratio that we've defined
so we have something and that looks like
this
now the thing with playing with aspect
ratio is you can do some really nice
things you can create some really nice
patterns by by sort of you know setting
an aspect ratio on boxes and i was sort
of noodling around with this little demo
this is basically a figure element
there's three images there and a fig
caption i've given the images one one
aspect ratio to the end of a perfect
square no matter you know how wide they
are based based on the the screen size
but they're always a square and i'm then
using grid to overlay the fig caption
across the three
and so i've just turned on the grid
there using dev tools so we've got you
know a 104 105 one of our three boxes um
and then i've got the the caption um
laid across the bottom
now the nice thing about defining aspect
ratio um it can help you to avoid layout
shift and because you can you can sort
of define boxes that you know that
you're going to need that size and
things can go into them
and in fact prior to the aspect ratio
property appearing in browsers browsers
were already using that property
internally
to copy the aspect ratio from the width
and height that was on the image element
so and and they do that so if you are
adding images to a page it's important
to put your width and height back on i
think we all stop doing it when we're
doing responsive design because we're
like we're sizing it using css now
but if you put the width and height onto
your images then the browser takes that
and it works at the aspect ratio and it
has a placeholder so you don't get that
horrible jiggling especially on a phone
as all the images load in and take up
their space
and that's a really good point to think
about what's kind of
coming into css this idea of considering
things like layout shift
because there's this specification
called css containment now i wrote about
this this contains the contain property
and the level one of the spec introduced
the contain property now what css
containment does
is it gives you a way to tell the
browser that this chunk of content
is like a sort of a closed box as it
were um nothing outside is going to
affect it and nothing inside that box
can affect things outside now that's
really useful if you are building you
know your your single page app
um
particularly you know you're using
javascript to change things on the page
now some of the stuff on the page you're
not going to change
it's never going to change it's like you
know stuff around the side it's not
going to be touched by the javascript so
you can use containment to sort of
define areas and it basically gives the
browser a hint
that you know things aren't going to
change in that in that element or when
things change inside that it doesn't
affect the outside the browser doesn't
for instance need to repaint everything
every time javascript interacts with the
page
so that's really useful so yeah you can
use this you use this contain property
and you know you can say contain layout
that's what nothing of the layout is is
going to change
so that is you know already there very
useful you know everybody should be
using that it's got very few side
effects to to use
but this coming into css
opened the door to solving something
that web developers have been asking for
for years now i for as long as i can
remember i have been you know doing
these talks talking to web developers
and i usually say
tell the css working group what you want
let us know what you're interested in
and like a tsunami
comes back container queries we want
container queries everybody wants
container queries it's like is that you
know that is the one thing no matter
what we give you you're still going to
ask us for container queries
and
it looks like we're going to get them
so container queries are basically like
media queries but instead of querying
the total size of the viewport and
making decisions based on that you know
you're querying the size of the
container that the item is in now the
work on this specification has been
mostly done by miriam suzanne who is
doing uh you know an amazing job working
through this this specification i am
just as usual a person standing around
talking about it and trying to explain
it
um so you know all of the credit for the
things that i'm showing you should you
know should definitely go um to her and
and do you know find stuff she's writing
about this to some of my resources and
to learn more
so
i think you know this need for container
queries has come about as people have
moved
into doing you know layouts based on
components a lot more you know we're
using pattern libraries and so on we're
designing components outside of layout
and then we're wanting to drop them into
layout
so the um the little figure component i
showed earlier now if the container
would say i dropped that also into a
sidebar for example um so the second
example here it's got a constrained
width now it works it goes really tiny
but you can't really see the images um
now it's if it's just the whole viewport
that's drinking obviously i can use
media queries and rebuild it but if i
just want to drop it into a smaller part
of the layout then knowing the viewport
size doesn't help me so that's really
what container queries are are here to
help us with
and we can try them out uh in chrome you
need if you're searching chrome flags
for enable css container queries the
demos i've got here which are in with my
links and you can actually try out so
now this spec is
in development there's sort of like
there's a there's a test version in
chrome it may well change yet it could
well like have changed by the time i get
home
um so but you know so to do keep an eye
on on sort of you know what what's been
said about it but you can go and you can
try try it out in chrome
so you need a container now that's
whatever is the parent of your
components or a pair and it doesn't have
your direct parent department of the
component
and you need to know which dimension
you're querying block in line or both
now i think for most people it's it's
the inline size which in english is the
width that's probably what you're going
to want to query and you want to know
how much available width you've got in
order to lay out your thing so we say
container type inline size so now we've
created a container that you know we
know about the inline size of this thing
now when you do that this is a bit like
using the contain property so you create
a containment context it will turn on
layout style and inline size containment
so that's exactly in the same way as
using the contain property does
now this will cause the box to do a
couple of things and you will only
notice something visually
if you have floats poking out of that
box because they will get contained that
when you get a new block format in
context and margins will stop collapsing
through so there's a potential of a
layout change when you make something a
container in really those two situations
and because when something
is a containment context it basically
keeps everything inside it and nothing
can kind of get out just like when you
use the contain property
but a lot of the time because actually
having floats poking out boxes and
margins collapsing through that's not
something we tend to be relying on in
our designs
but you might see a change
um you can also optionally
name a container so you can give it a
name if you want and that means you can
actually query then a container with a
specific name rather than just going for
the next the next sort of parent
container
so that's option you can give things a
name
and then once you've got your container
you can query it and it's pretty much
just like using media queries at that
point
so you can see if your container in this
case i'm not using the name so it's just
going to go for the next container that
it finds
and then we can do our css inside just
in the same way that we would do media
queries
and that's if you've got a name you can
do you know at container and then the
name the names are just like um using
say if you sort of name areas in grid
you use an ident it's the same kind of
rules apply for creating your names you
can call them pretty much anything you
like
um and and it's it's an ident rather
than a string so they're not quoted
so this is a little demo and i've got
three fixed width grid columns and one
taking the remaining space it's one fr
so the reason the last two have turned
blue is that the third is in a 300 pixel
grid track and the fourth uses fr units
and resolving to greater than 220 pixels
so that's just a line we're just sort of
checking in and using container queries
there to change the color
as a little test but if we look at the
example i was showing you
before
you can see here how i've got a
different display of that example and
i'm pretty much in this example and it
you can go and have a look at it with my
resources i'm
pretty much doing this like when you do
like a mobile first layout and so i'm
sort of deciding my small layout first
um creating that so this is a two column
grid layout
and then when i have got enough space
then i will use
the the larger layout the one that i
created before so i think that the
minute you get your hands on this it's
going to be so familiar from using media
queries because essentially it works in
just the same way but you're you know
querying the container rather than the
um
than the viewport and and you can
combine the two of course you can have
things that that are using media queries
and container queries
to say you know
seems pretty straightforward
and i think what a lot of people are
going to be saying is hang on
why is this taken years
what were you doing
and i think the thing is
that
although this is specification wise
relatively simple we just couldn't have
done it a few years ago like a lot of
the complex layout stuff we're now able
to do a lot of this is built on the fact
that browsers have just got a lot better
the thing about handing over something
like container queries
is that it is simple and it's really
useful and we're all going to use it all
over the place
and if that had then slowed everything
to a crawl and made all you know web
pages just respond awfully
that wouldn't be very good you know so
something that we care about a lot when
we're adding you know where platform
features is you know is it is it going
to work well is it going to perform well
you know are we not doing something that
is going to make the web worse
and so that's really what we've been
waiting for we've been waiting for
browsers to get to a point where we can
do this without making the web worse um
and that really i think is is is why you
know for a long time that was that was
why we didn't do container queries was
just well how would we do this and it
performed well um and your browser has
been doing a lot of work to
give us the ability to do new cool stuff
um so chrome have been working on this
on this project rendering ng and this
sort of the rewrite of the engine um and
the sort of part that's most of interest
to me and people who care about css and
css layout is the part called layout ng
this is a post um on the chrome
developers blog sort of doing a real dig
there's actually a big series of these
posts which are quite technical but but
really quite interesting um in terms of
how
you know how
rendering ng is making some things
possible that weren't possible before
and speeding up a bunch of stuff that we
already have like grid layouts for
example um and fixing a load of bugs you
know sort of weird bugs in flex books
and so there's little things that you
might hit up against
things in fragmentation which which have
been difficult to do in the past you
know all this sort of stuff is getting
fixed um through layout ng so that's
really exciting loads of table books and
stuff there's loads of really weird
books in in table layout um you know
that you can run into these sort of
things um are being fixed so i you know
i would recommend going and if you've
got a bit of an interest in how browsers
do this stuff and and you know how we're
getting things in browsers these posts
are really interesting so that's really
why it's taking a long time it's not
because the css working group hate you
it's because
this stuff's just hard and potentially
causes all sorts of problems and what we
want to do is be able to give you stuff
that is going to be really cool and work
very well
there's a few of the bits and bobs um
so you could as a shorthand which lets
you specify your type of containment and
the name
using that forward slash syntax that we
see in grid layout as well
you can do things like block size and
this is a little bit influx at the
moment even in the spec i was i was
asking miriam a few questions about it i
had some kind of components in mind that
i can't quite build yet and
they they would they sort of rely on on
block containment
now the thing about querying um the
block dimension well the thing about the
web generally is we don't actually tend
to know how tall things are that's been
a kind of a good maxim of web
development and design um you know you
can control how wide things are but you
never know how tall anything is on the
web and especially when we go back to
floats uh we we never knew how tall
things were going to turn out um the
thing is when you query the
block dimension it's a bit like when you
use containment in the block dimension
if you use size containment you're
basically saying i know how big this
thing is i know how tall this thing is
if you're talking about block in english
now if you see if you haven't set an
explicit height on the thing
then it basically acts like it's got no
size so it all kind of collapses down um
that is that's just what happens with
containment because actually there isn't
a size to that thing it's just getting
as tall as it is for the content um i
know that's something that sort of is is
being thought about you know ways around
you know how to deal with that well
so
container queries you know are coming
now
i i say that now you have to remember i
was the person who talked about grid
layout on stage for five full years
before it launched so i've got something
of a track record
in css vaporware
so
i do believe they're coming um i i
imagine it's probably going to be a
couple of years really by the time we
you know we've already heard a bit about
safari and things and
um how long it takes for things to get
into browsers but it does take a while
things to get into browsers and we can't
you know browser teams are busy and they
have their own um things to be working
on and and you know how quickly stuff
will land across browser i don't know
and even how quickly the spec is ready
really for it to come out from behind a
flag and chrome i don't know that either
but then they are coming um and but what
i really wanted to sort of show with
this talk and the progression i went
through is that
i don't want people to wait for this
thing they think is going to solve all
their problems to come because i think
actually
within existing layout methods an awful
lot of what you want out of container
queries you can already do
because of the way that
you know these new layout methods can
sort of do sizing and can respond to
what's inside them and outside them
there's an awful lot of stuff you can do
with creating flexible components just
by using grid and flexbox in an
intelligent way and really looking at
what they're meant to do and that
understanding will help you even once
you've got container queries because
they will help you do fallbacks because
it you know say say they land in chrome
and you think well you know a lot of our
users using chrome let's start to use
container queries as enhancement but
you're still going to want to use
something as a fallback
for your container queries
and it's also going to help you to not
clutter your code with lots and lots of
queries because we know from media
queries you know if you're using loads
and loads of media queries it gets quite
complicated and so if you add to that
the container queries you're adding a
lot of complexity so if you can just use
layout methods as they are and and use
what we've got before you start to add
in the queries i think you're going to
have you know much more straightforward
css you're not going to be creating a
lot of extra complexity
so remember that flexbox is designed for
flexible things you know a bunch of
different sized items with an unknown
container size it's really good at that
sort of stuff
use intrinsic and range sizing methods
with grid look at the different ways
that you can size you know tracks and
elements and so on
in in grid and don't restrict grid to be
only used for like the whole layout of
your page it's great for components um
you know like that little header you
know making a heading into a grid and
that might see if you have in your mind
the grid is you know only for making
fixed grids you miss out on a lot of
this really neat stuff where you can use
it for small components
so do remember that
but
do get excited for container queries try
it out enable the flag in chrome see if
the things you've had in your head when
you've been thinking i wish we had
container queries see if it works for
them and if it doesn't you know raise an
issue with with the css working group
you know ask me on twitter or one of the
other people working on the spec talk to
us because this is the chance to make it
this the sort of specification that we
really need this is the time to offer
that feedback so so please do please try
the stuff out that people are showing
you
and let us know what you think and thank
you very much it is wonderful to be back
in front of a real audience and i hope
you have been enjoying this conference
[Applause]